we now have a Joe Biden the economy is
in shambles we're nearing World War III
all of the things Trump said that were
going to happen have happened or are
happening or about to happen
and regular people are wondering why it
costs six bucks for a dozen eggs
so you can't run the guy again because
all of these problems that have been
going on for years people ain't happy
about yeah do you think you think
they're going to run someone else I'm
saying they're going after Trump
desperately because they don't have a
candidate because who are they going to
run Kamala no like there's no obvious
alternative I mean Ojo Biden was
supposed to be the end of the Old Guard
welcoming in this new era and you know
Noah
that's their best bet I bet they would
it's the only thing they would have
Ronda Santos if they wanted basically
Trump enough I mean obviously they just
give up and they're alive well the only
person who can be Trump they like
nominate Joe manchin because he's a
Democrat but like he's the best they can
do